a dangerous and fast-moving wildfire is
out of control in Northern California
the Pony fire is just 20 miles from
where a deadly fire devastated the
state's wine country last year a new
fire has destroyed a dozen structures
including 10 homes more than 600 other
buildings are at risk now this fire has
already burned through 77 hundred acres
forcing 2,500 people to evacuate in the
area it's one of five active wildfires
across California others are burning as
far away as Colorado New Mexico and
Texas mark Strassmann is in clear low
clear lake oaks it's called near 1
evacuated community mark good morning to
you good morning this is one of the 10
homes here inside the fire zone that
burned to the ground on Saturday for the
people who live here there's nothing to
come home to and it gets worse they may
have nothing to drive to find a new
place to live there are three vehicles
on this property all of them like this
one burned to scrap and ash and there's
still no word whether any of this fire
has been contained
the Pawnee fire burned through the night
fierce winds have pushed the flames
through thousands of acres of dry
Northern California brush since Saturday
as you can see behind me it's still
burning actively up in these mountains
it's just a combination of these dry
fuels the steep topography and now these
winds on top of it this is changing
extremely quickly it's still zero
percent contained at least 10 homes of
burn authorities have ordered the
evacuations of the nearby community of
Spring Valley where firefighters worked
furiously to protect structures but some
were still reduced to ash evacuees know
the worst might not be over yet your
neighbors are ok rugged terrain has
proved challenging for firefighters as
they try to protect homes air tankers
were dropping thousands of gallons of
retardant helicopters were dropping
hundreds of gallons of water all in an
effort to slow the progress around these
structures and they're really core
on the ground for many living in this
area responding to wildfires has become
a devastating part of everyday life
I've been evacuated whole six times the
last five years there's nothing new but
this is the closest one another major
fire is burning roughly 80 miles to the
northeast the so-called
lane fire has also forced evacuations as
it charred around 3,000 acres
threatening hundreds of structures there
and to give you a sense of this fires
heat this is actually melted aluminum
from the rims of the wheels of this car
think about that melted aluminum there
is still no sense of when folks here are
going to be allowed to return the good
news is though is that the the winds
have gonna die down probably both today
and tomorrow firefighters could use the
help
Bojana hopefully some help from Mother
Nature mark thank you